I love you so much
which really means
I am partly mistaking you for
somebody else
I will later blame you for not being who I imagined
without checking you were.
I will try to change you
i will
try
to posses you
then resent you
for trapping me
i will
one day
think of other people
when  we make love
I will expect you to understand
what I am feeling
without me
ever telling you
I will attribute all my joys
and more particularly
all my sorrows to you
it will always be your fault
I will use you to pretend we are not all
fundamentally alone.
I will blame you for having ruined my life
and you will do the same
please be my valentine